[Musique]
plan de mandature du conseil
départemental de la réunion 2021 2028 un
plan qui sera appelée à évoluer au fil
du temps pour s'adapter aux difficultés
aux contraintes chaque année la mise en
oeuvre du projet départemental sera
évaluée pour chacune des dix ambitions
sous la responsabilité des élus
concernés avec vous pour créer un vivre
ensemble qui favorise l'inclusion de
tous et de chacun
première ambition renforcer l'accès au
droit et à la prévention répondre à
l'urgence sociale il s'agit de renforcer
l'accueil de proximité sur les sites du
département accessibilité des locaux
pour les personnes porteuses de handicap
amélioration de l'accès aux services
publics modernisation des équipements et
formation des agents avec l'état et la
région accompagner les usagers notamment
les plus âgés à la maîtrise des outils
numériques des caravanes accès au droit
sillonneront aisée car l'arbre des
personnes en situation de fragilité
sociale un dispositif expérimental
d'alors quartier sera lancée pour aider
à l'accomplissement des démarches
administratives un plan départemental de
prévention sera proposée sur plusieurs
thématiques parentalité violence
ordinaire gestion budgétaire addiction
obésité maladies infectueuses manzano
l'aide financière aux centres
d'hébergement d'urgence pour les femmes
avec enfants notamment celles qui sont
victimes de violence met en place d'une
astreinte social après 16 heures de
nouvelles idées de nouveaux dispositifs
seront proposés aux bénéficiaires du rsa
pour favoriser leur insertion
deuxième ambition accompagner les
parents protéger des enfants et
favoriser leur réussite création d'un
site dédié la parentalité dans chaque
canton renforcement de l'accompagnement
des parents pendant la grossesse et les
premières années de la vie de l'enfant
soutien aux porteurs de projets de garde
d'enfants la protection maternelle et
infantile sera étoffée recentrer sur
l'émission préventive met en place de
nouvelles actions de lutte contre les
violences faites aux enfants avec de
nouveaux moyens engagés dans l'aide
sociale à l'enfance le plan de
recrutement pluriannuel d assistante
familiale permettra de faire face aux
nombreux départs l'augmentation du
nombre d'enfants confiés à la zone
l'observatoire départemental de la
protection de l'enfance bénéficiera de
moyens techniques et humains pour jouer
son rôle de coordination des acteurs et
de force de proposition
programme ambitieux protéger accompagner
les plus vulnérables soutien au maintien
à domicile des personnes âgées en perte
d'autonomie mais en place d'actions de
prévention la dépendance pour favoriser
un vieillissement en bonne santé mais en
place d'un programme de structuration et
de professionnalisation de l'aide à
domicile renforcement du soutien du
département aux cédants renforçons
également de l'aide aux publics fragiles
souhaitant passer du statut de locataire
à celui de propriétaire afin de mélanger
les publics fragiles le département
élargira ses actions de réhabilitation
de l'habitat un plus grand nombre de
bénéficiaires dans le cadre du fonds de
solidarité pour le logement dispositif à
gestion partenariale la collectivité
accentuera son accompagnement des
ménages éprouvant des difficultés pour
accéder à un logement décent et
indépendant ou s'y maintenir concernant
l'accueil familial les accueillants
familiaux seront formés à l'évolution
des profils des publics d'accompagner en
ce qui concerne l'offre médico social
pour les personnes âgées en direction
des structures d'hébergement la
collectivité s'engage dans la création
la rénovation d pad avec des places
d'accueil avec hébergement pour les
personnes en situation de handicap
[Musique]
avec vous pour amener toutes les
générations sur les chômeurs de leur
réussite 4e ambitions favoriser la
réussite des jeunes en faire des
citoyens la politique départementale
favorise l'épanouissement
l'enrichissement et l'ouverture dégénéré
à l'extérieur ce soutien se voient
forcés notamment en direction des plus
fragilisés le département poursuivra ses
actions facilitant l'accès des jeunes
aux droits s'investir à côté du rectorat
dans l'information des collégiens sur la
rotation et dans la prévention du
décrochage scolaire un coaching
personnalisé sera proposée en parallèle
aux allocataires du rsa âgés de 25 à 49
ans et la collectivité proposera aux
étudiants mobilité qui le souhaitent un
accompagnement individuel à partir de la
rentrée 2022 l'effort d'équipement
numérique des collèges et
l'accompagnement des jeunes dans la
maîtrise des usages numériques soient
complétées par des actions de
sensibilisation aux risques liés à
l'utilisation d'internet les
départements souhaite également
favoriser l'engagement et la créativité
en donnant aux jeunes réunionnais la
possibilité de s'exprimer de développer
leur citoyenneté il recensera son
soutien aux actions facultative dans les
collèges et encouragera les jeunes à
mener des actions citoyennes dans les
associations ou dans des sociétés
publiques locales qu'ils financent
5e ambitions démocratiser la culture
valoriser le patrimoine promouvoir le
sport cette mandature sera marquée par
la mise en oeuvre du chantier du musée
historique de l'habitation de
l'esclavagé villèle la collectivité
soutiendra la création de supports
d'appropriation du patrimoine par le
grand public et de parcours mémorielle
et l'encouragera la réhabilitation des
lieux historiques et patrimoniaux et le
tourisme culturel sur les sites dédiés
afin de démocratiser l'accès à la
culture des supports inventif seront
déployés en direction des publics
sociaux en particulier des personnes
âgées des personnes porteuses de
handicap le département continuera de
soutenir les projets des artistes des
associations culturelles et d'une
culture en accordant une attention
particulière aux projets privés l'hégire
l'accessibilité la tarification modéré
la délocalisation l'éducation tice tic
et culturel dans le domaine du sport
augmentation du nombre de clubs
bénéficiaires de ces subventions tout en
initiant en accompagnant des projets de
structuration des sports émergents
notamment les sports de pleine nature
dans le même temps il renforcera son
soutien au sport de haut niveau
avec vous pour créer une agriculture
locale et responsable pour l'avenir de
notre île 6e ambition accompagner la
réunion vers une agriculture durable
visant la souveraineté alimentaire le
département poursuivra la mise en oeuvre
du plan des pays 2030 qui a l'ambition
de développer l'agriculture réunionnaise
en privilégiant modèle familial durable
et diversifiée
l'atteinte de cet objectif passe par la
préservation du foncier agricole et la
remise en culture des terres en friche
qui sera amplifié produire plus et
produire mieux en soutenant la
diversification végétale et animale des
exploitations en aval des filières de
production faciliter la transformation
des produits locaux et la
commercialisation en circuits courts
renforcement de la visibilité des pros
du pays sur les différents segments du
marché une marque collective
territoriale au bénéfice exclusif des
produits agricoles 100% pays sera créé
ainsi qu'une ferme expérimentale vitrine
de l'action de la collectivité destiné à
favoriser l'installation la formation et
l'insertion des jeunes dans les métiers
de l'agriculture
les départements pour suivre enfin son
action structurante dans la gestion de
l'eau agricole afin d'irriguer 1500
hectares supplémentaires
avec vous pour agir durablement et
préserver notre île
c'est l'ambition faire de la ruralité en
espace majeur de l'aménagement de notre
territoire le département s'engage à
valoriser les territoires ruraux
notamment les eaux dans sa stratégie
d'aménagement l'équipement du territoire
sera rééquilibré en portant une
attention particulière à la microrégion
est moins dotées que les autres en
équipement structurant le soutien aux
communes sera également conforté à
travers le pacte de solidarité
territoriale un programme d'amélioration
et le développement du réseau routier
départemental sera d'autre part mais son
oeuvre en tant qu'autorité de gestion du
programme feader et en liaison avec le
projet a day pays de winthrop la
collectivité mobilisera les dispositifs
européens comme levier de développement
des projets portés par les acteurs
locaux la collectivité s'attachera dans
le même temps à créer de l'activité sur
le foncier qu'elles maîtrisent notamment
dans la zone arrière portuaires ou
autour de la ressource thermale de
cilaos propriétaire d'un patrimoine
naturel d'exception le département
poursuivra l'aménagement des grands
sites et la mise en valeur des paysages
de l'île afin de répondre aux exigences
dans tourisme d'excellence tout en
accompagnant le développement de
l'agritourisme
[Musique]
huitième mission préserver valoriser
durablement de ressources en maximisant
la collectivité a adopté le plan
départemental de transition écologique
et solidaire feuille de route qui
guidera son action dans les prochaines
années dans ce cadre la politique du
département visant à inverser la
tendance à la perte de biodiversité sera
renforcée avec des programmes ambitieux
de lutte contre les espèces invasives et
de reboisement de lille la plantation
d'un million d'arbres dans le milieu
naturel et dans les espaces publics
urbains et périurbains est notamment en
cours de mise en oeuvre avec l'office de
l'eau un programme de rénovation des
réseaux d'eau potable sera également
lancée tout comme un programme
d'équipement des ménages pour le
stockage et la réutilisation de l'eau de
pluie dans le domaine de la production
agricole le département soutiendra le
développement des productions bio local
et de l'agroforesterie
le département veut devenir une
collectivité électricité positive dès
2023 pour réduire sa production de
déchets non recyclables promouvoir
l'achat local et durable
son administration fera évoluer ses
pratiques afin d'atteindre ses objectifs
et des actions seront menées pour
impliquer toutes les générations dans la
transition écologique
avec vous pour renforcer nos liens dans
l'océan indien
deuxième ambition développer ces
échanges et la solidarité dans l'océan
indien la politique de coopération
régionale du département vise un
développement solidaire et à la lutte
contre les inégalités mondiales ces
actions doivent bénéficier aux
populations concernées et contribuer à
renforcer les compétences de ses
partenaires le département continuera à
soutenir les programmes visant à
améliorer la sécurité alimentaire et
nutritionnelle de long terme en rhodia
aussi à nîmes en particulier à
madagascar et aux comores échanges de
bonnes pratiques agricoles transfert des
innovations contribuer à la réduction de
la pauvreté à l'accès à l'eau et à
l'éducation à la préservation de
l'environnement la collectivité en
fonction à son soutien en échange d'
expertise réciproque à l'échelle
régionale et à la valorisation des
compétences réunionnaises dans les
domaines de l'agriculture de la maîtrise
de l'eau l'enseignement du français le
renforcement des liens entre les
populations de l'océan indien reste une
priorité pour le département dans les
domaines de la culture et du sport le
soutien aux missions de volontaires du
service civique à l'international et de
volontaires de solidarité internationale
sera maintenue dans un esprit de
réciprocité accueille les jeunes
volontaires de pays de la zone sera
encouragée
avec vous pour faciliter la vie de tous
les réunionnais cadeaux chaque citoyen
10e ambitions simplifier les démarches
de nos publics le département a
l'ambition de mener une action publique
davantage orienté vers l'usager plus
efficace dans la réponse à ces besoins
plus transparente dans ces résultats la
simplification des processus et des
procédures impliquera des adaptations de
son organisation et de ses modes de
gestion ainsi qu'un accompagnement
changement l'amélioration de l'accueil
et la modernisation du versement des
aides s'appuieront notamment sur de
nouveaux outils numériques
l'expérimentation sera encouragé le
département mettra en place des
formations sur la conduite de projets et
des méthodes d'innovation public avant
d'essaimer de nouvelles pratiques dans
l'ensemble des services l'évaluation et
la mesure de la performance seront
développés dans le but de déceler les
dysfonctionnements de corriger de
réorienter les projets si besoin les
départements poursuivre l'exercice de
transparence engagé dépit 2018
permettant aux citoyens de s'assurer que
les comptes de la collectivité sont
sincères la communication sur ces
projets sera favorisée par la mise en
oeuvre de l'open data des solutions sont
également expérimenté pour mieux
associer les citoyens la construction
des politiques publiques départementales
[Musique]